I want to welcome those of you who have
visit us and are visiting us today as
part of the open house I hope all of you
are enjoying your time at the school and
I speak for the students and faculty
when I say we enjoy having you here
after tonight's lecture please join our
speakers our students and faculty in a
reception in the architecture gallery on
the second floor I am delighted to
welcome Todd Williams and Billie Tsien
back as Luis icon visiting professors
hardly strangers in our midst as
visitors they first offered an advance
to do here at Yale in 1992 and have
returned six subsequent times since fall
2000 in 2003 we were honored to exhibit
their work in our gallery todd williams
and billie tsien are superb teachers
with a deep commitment to students as
individuals sharing with them an
exploration of the craft and the
composition of architecture they are
eloquent with their words but their real
poetry is the exploration of materials
and matter as can be seen in there
recently completed and universally
acclaimed Barnes Museum in Philadelphia
the work of Williams and Jen stands
apart from the noise and early burley of
so much contemporary practice the
intensity of their approach makes each
Williams and Jen building special but
their's is not only an architecture of
craft and detail there's a site-specific
and program specific their buildings are
strong but they are also subtle tod
williams billie tsien are longtime
collaborators in life and in the office
but they don't always see eye to eye
which makes their times together on the
platform at recent past experience holds
any relevance particularly interesting
they agreed to just
agree which is kind of our Yale way and
as they resolve their debate we in the
audience benefit immensely from the
exchange of ideas todd williams is a
graduate of Princeton nobody's perfect
Billy Chen is a graduate of Yale and
UCLA please join me in welcoming todd
williams and billie tsien as they
deliver the lecture a deliberate
architecture
thank you thank you Bob it's been great
working here under you and it's a great
school and all the better because of you
really mean it so we thought we would
spend some time talking about why we do
what we do and of course we'll show you
what we do but we'd like to think about
why for a little bit let's talk about a
deliberate architecture Hey okay well
yes yeah I've got you I've got to be
further away I mean delivered
architecture also is a deliberate
practice and the deliberate practice
actually comes from being able to have
separate ideas and come together as a
single hole it's not just our two ideas
it's our studio it's our client and so
on and we have to we like the idea of
making certain that this is an
increasing we're always increasing our
expertise and learning more we're not
we're building on past experience with
its models that went before paradigms or
own work one of the things that it turns
out there is a term called deliberate
prac deliberate practice and essentially
what they're talking about is not
getting better because you're innately
more talented but by continuing to sort
of hone your craft and so I think in
many ways that's how what I would say is
the way we approach our work beliefs
well this is a tough one what is beliefs
its house practically religious Billy
and I have worked hard to agree on
certain things which is number one
thankee we're producing architecture
this is what we do this is our passion
we actually believe that foundational
principle of architecture is to be abuse
it's a service but I think many people
will think of service and equate it with
being survial and I don't think that
that's really true at all I think when
you answer a need you can also
or to transcend your answer and in that
way it really becomes very very noble so
I think architecture has bility and be
an incredibly noble noble way of living
your life and being abused is also a
great way to be powerful quietly
powerful to be useful to move slowly
this really comes more from Billy than
for me I mean we are definitely in a
world that seems to move ever faster and
in this world we've decided that it's
better for us to move as slowly as
possible which is frustrating to all
sorts of people but we're not going to
move that slowly tonight so I promise to
get you out of here within a reasonable
amount of time so what you'll see is we
actually trade positions but essentially
we're balancing each other because we'd
like to make all decisions carefully and
with reflections or reflection is a huge
amount what we feel is part of the
process of design well we work on all
projects together and because we see
life so differently it's very difficult
to come to a consensus where I believe
that the decision is utterly mine and
Billy believes it's utterly hers you
always believe the decision is utter
layers not bad ones
to say no I mean actually this is a
really important one as a young person I
couldn't discern right from wrong or if
I did it was in a very very black and
white way and I think that it was
difficult to determine how to say what
you wanted to do and so in many ways I
think I've helped to form at least
myself by being able to say what I won't
do and in a way seeing what you don't do
won't do is just as powerful in saying
what you will do the fact sometimes more
powerful because architecture touches so
many different things and there are so
many possibilities out there that it's
easy to say yes well I think when you're
young of course you say yes to most
everything but I think over time we
realized that it's very useful to be
able to say no so actually one of the
things that you'll see tonight is that
we for this talk I thought how many
projects have we actually done and I
think we didn't really know that and son
since we started working together in
nineteen seventy seven or eight we've
done no more than 50 total projects that
are complete that includes installations
interiors and so and so we're working at
about an average of one plus something a
year so we do move slowly and we've had
to say we've said no to a lot of things
which has helped us to form and be
stronger when we say yes so we have two
words here to belong or to connect and
it's because we have a slight
disagreement on which one we would
choose yeah I've used the word belong
that Billy doesn't want to belong in my
white man's club so hard to belong in
his white man's crown
but I think we want our work to actually
feel like it's connective in every way
that it not only belongs to the past but
it belongs to the present and if it
really belongs to the past of the
present then it actually probably has
some traction in the future so I think
you'll see that one of the things in or
all of the projects we're going to show
today and in fact of the 50 total
projects this is going to horrify you we
will actually probably show 30 of the
projects 25 very very quickly indicating
each of these values and trying all of
the projects have all of the values
because that's also one of the things
we've been doing is negotiating these
for nearly 50 years all right yeah now
okay so you're to last that would be
good not all buildings last but our idea
our belief is that we want to do work
that lasts that outlives are our lives
and so we take it very seriously these
marks that we make and see them not
clearly as our children but many way
they are extensions of not only me but
Billy and all the people in the studios
who work that lasts is terribly
important you have a different opinion
so there are a series of topics that we
are going to go through and we're going
to show you some ways that we've sort of
looked at these topics in terms and
they're sort of very much formed by that
set of beliefs and the first one is the
powerful presence of the land actually
yes go this is somewhat chronological
the date here in 1988 in addition to a
suburban house in Kings Point and the
owners needed they were he was becoming
infirm and had needed to exercise in the
pool they collected art and we added a
wing to their bedroom that where he
could exercise they're no longer with us
but the pine trees were pine trees that
he planted when they first were married
and so we wanted to nestle this small
room into the trees and it shares of you
as the arrow indicates with the view of
the living but neither can see each
other house in Phoenix outside of
Phoenix and it was built on either side
up in Arroyo and so in the rainy season
the water rushes through it still
remains the one sort of stream of green
through the property so we built two
bars on either side and there's
straddling the stream is an interior
space and also a bridge and I would say
this also
indicates other themes that exist you'll
see materiality as Bob said but this
indicates as the previous one is
actually we're sharing a landscape with
another piece so in a way we're creating
a very small compound there are actually
two bridges that cross the Arroyo and
two sun shades that then protect that
Arroyo one of bridges and interior
bridge and the other one is next to your
bridge this project the neurosciences
Institute so it's a very early early
sketch but the drawing shows that the
land is really cut down and the
buildings are set into the cut so things
that have to have started to happen in
our work our buildings are pulled apart
to allow the lend or something important
to flow through and then often we're
interested in cutting down into the
ground wait it's the sense of place to
that this is trying to deliver a sense
of place in the land as formed by the
buildings and and I would say that this
is the first time we really buried our
buildings and i would say about
one-third of the entire project is
deeply is under 10 to 12 feet of soil
and those eucalyptus trees that are
there now very very large tree so this
was shortly after planting and then this
house in Long Island with very very tall
block pine trees and once again you can
see that the house is sort of fragmented
into pieces or separate in pieces and
once again as in the first pool house
every room looks out to a different view
but you never really are aware of
additional parts of the house and this
house is not air conditioned what was
the date 98 it and has
an air-conditioned comfortably for the
last 16 years but we use cross
ventilation and by allowing the land to
do the work the building sits
comfortably and something sometimes a
very warm climate so here's another
project at Johns Hopkins where we've
taken a project and actually also buried
it in the land three buildings separated
and united by the walls and a courtyard
so in the section you can see how the
building is cut in and thus far
photograph shows it at the campus level
so that there are just these very very
low buildings and then you descend on
the stairs and you're in this courtyard
so all of this goes to say that in the
ideal our buildings are subservient to
the land or if they're not subservient
to the land that they are at least not
trying to dominate the land and I think
that's I think they're in a relationship
and partnership they're never
subservient okay okay except that they
are they belong to the land does that
work they connect to the line okay they
belong and in their place okay well okay
the presence of the human hand this is
actually is very important and it also
connects to the obviously the issue of
crafts and in this this is the
neurosciences good staying busy picture
Billy actually pulling out a wooden a
piece of that was a eucalyptus leaf that
she carved one of her great model making
exercises placed in the form work and
when removed and gives us sort of sense
of place we used to do this a lot which
is to make sure as people once did
there's a presence of in hand I was here
the worker was here everyone contributes
to the making of architecture and we
still believe that
and then of course the facade of the
folk art museum where every panel was
cast up at talax foundry so each panel
really had a sense of difference from
one to the other this idea of a tile we
worked for a number of years actually
since the early 90s with Heath tile
using first their standard tiles and
then asking them to make small changes
to their tiles like this one which has a
thumbprint in it well we went out to
their factory and it's great because you
see the clay being formed and so the
question was could you deform a tile so
that it had the sense of it being both
uniform and different from each other
and so then was well can you just stick
your finger in it it was a lot of tiles
it would have been very sad finger but
they made a dye and then they
essentially dropped it you know onto the
end of the clay but what happens is the
way that the enamel pools it makes each
tile also played widely and this is
cloudy youngster where we've often
collaborated we always feel that whether
it's the plumber or the stonemason in
this case cloudy youngster who's a
felting artist from northern Neville
Neville ins friesland using her own
sheep's wool and the dyes that she gets
from her garden doing a mural or two
murals for us and this from the Barnes
Foundation so we went to look at the
stone in the Negev desert and while
we're there we went to the finishing
Factory and saw that although what we
saw in the sample rooms were simply very
large or very smooth pieces of stone you
could actually have them and chiseled
and that's really why we were able to
use different kinds of two
on the facade of that stone he's there
and the handrail detail from one
apartment actually a drawing that first
came from a desire to do something was a
little like a drawn line to take care of
the handrail and a diameter which was a
little three-quarter heavy but which
couldn't make those radiuses unless it
was solid so an ironmonger then worked
to take the drawing and then make this
this railing which actually strengthens
itself as it turns corners and becomes a
place where you can put your hand so
it's not only made by hand but it
suggests the place of the end presence
of material so it's interesting to think
of the common materials that are around
us and try to imagine how they might be
reused so this is really from a very
early installation that was done at the
Walker Art Center with Mickey Friedman
who has just recently passed away but
this is Hama so and it's a common tack
board material but we thought if you
laminated it you could use it as a solid
and carve into it well we actually
bought a six foot high stack of houma
sewed 8 foot by four foot sheets and
wanted to see how much we could mine
from it and then whether we could put it
back together whether it could be
benches into a wall or stairs and then
this show that we did was an
installation for summoner Gucci's Akari
and we wanted to have a
light-transmitting way of separating the
spaces so that you could see one Lantern
separate from another so we made these
very simple fiberglass screens so a
caray means light and and these were
light sculptures and we wanted the
sculpture to both be visible as you saw
it but also to be itself a shielded from
one another so there was a one preceded
the scene of the Akari by the light
transmitted through the Akari and then
the fiberglass
no so this is an installation in Finland
we worked with an artist named Karsten
holler and he's very interested in
slides and the phenomenon of movement
and so this was actually something that
is not seen from above because it was
flush with the surface of the ground and
then the snow is dug out into a series
of channels and you go in the little
hole at the top and you can see in the
model and you go sliding down to the
hole at the bottom really answer the
slide but anyway it's it's really just
done in a depression in the land about a
six-foot depression finally these are
really common walk off Matt's you see
Best Western there we wanted very very
cheap art and so we found out how they
made the best western walk off Matt's
and it turns out that you could get your
own pattern done for five hundred
dollars it would have a rubber backing
with a block off Matt so we at the east
asian library we couldn't afford art so
we scanned images from their library and
then produced these are collages that we
produced and made them art on the wall
so they're both sound absorbent and no
inexpensive they're not are they were
art they would be expensive
there might be expensive it might be
trash yeah okay and then at the barnes
foundation using the stone actually that
was the stone of the floor surface and
making it into a mosaic that is based on
an African textile so all of these are
different ways by which we in a way add
detail to our work our first projects
together were all interiors I built
nothing until I was in mid 40s that was
on the ground and so all of the
freestanding work individual buildings
are since that time this is again
working with Heath I think one of the
things we did in the beginning we were
much more involved in the fabrication
and I think now what we're also doing is
trying to understand how we can use the
resources that exist and that are
essentially ignored because a lot of
times they're quite but now and think
about reusing them in a certain way so
as Todd says this is heath it's their
standard tile and it's been dipped a
second time so there's our double dip
tiles another thing we can do as
architects is that by working with a
single vendor like Heath we've actually
changed the way they manufacture their
tiles it used to be they had a huge
amount of waste because we've done this
more recent we've asked them to use
reuse all of their waste grind up all of
the waste the glaze and the body and now
they're making a new range of tiles more
irregular but with a golden color so
nothing is ever lost so working with one
vendor and even not very strong
architects can actually begin to change
the way people do business specificity
CH place dormitory at Princeton I think
that the this is clearly a postmodern
building what is the date in 86 well it
started way before that and it was to be
a a building that wanted to fit into the
neo-gothic campus and it basically
twists slightly away from the old
neo-gothic buildings and action
I kind of foil between buildings of the
1960's that are also knew nothing nice
to it it's over there these are the 60s
building so it's a freestanding building
minutes just show how things have
changed at the 40 person dormitory built
in 1986 that came in 1.1 million dollars
and we were criticized deeply for coming
in a hundred thousand over budget so
times have changed it'll change for all
of us and then in Phoenix where the
museum is on a quite busy street phoenix
being primarily place where every woman
drives making a big wall and then making
a huge roof and the roof extends beyond
the interior space so that it's really a
place of sheet well becomes a shade and
also becomes a beacon without actually
creating a sense of the noise you
momently past behind that concrete wall
it's a quiet place at skirt can at all
we wanted to both belong but stand apart
we don't always just want to belong this
is a brick building in a brick context
with two listed buildings on either side
and here we developed a new kind of
brick and actually a machine-made brick
that has an automatic dent in it and
double dipped and then back to the
Barnes Foundation wanting to connection
so we went I said to the negev to find a
stone but it is basically a limestone so
Indiana limestone was very very
consistent and was the stone that was
used primarily along the Franklin
Parkway but it's also very flat so once
again it's about connecting and standing
apart at the same time I mean a perfect
example is too
that the limestone that was mine a
hundred years ago is much more varied
than the clean limestone that Indiana
produces today and so we wanted to
simultaneously connect it be more rich
and varied here we have just finished a
project at mcdowell where our connection
is just to connect to a library which we
see on I think your left yes the savage
library from 1910 or so mad a new wing
this is the one room library and this is
a series of room but we added a third
component actually a second component
which is a fireplace a place to gather
before you go into the library so the
macdowell colony as you may know is a
place where artists and writers can go
and spend a period of time it's in new
hampshire and so we wanted to sort of
both speak to the climate there and then
also that sense of the stones with the
Granite State and finally focus on the
interior we think that the interior is
an ark our students are getting a dose
of it are very very important Todd it
always says that you know it's the
interior of people that you really care
about the exterior sort of change but
it's the interior of people and so
partly it's because we started out doing
interior work but we still always very
much design from the inside out so the
project the interior this this project
is a competitive swimming pool which
doesn't use air conditioning but uses
natural ventilation and the building
today is converge likum pletely hidden
in the pine trees behind the pine trees
here it looks out into the pines when
the windows and walls are open you smell
the plans you don't smell chlorine so
that's a sensual and a competitive
right it's an interior experience for
someone even doesn't particularly care
essential experience for someone that
doesn't care about something like Billy
this is a library it's a good place to
read a blood this is a library in a
public school we did three of these four
of these I'm sorry where we took in this
particular case for classrooms who are
not being used and created a library
using obviously this this scalar device
to unify the spaces and to help to break
up the scale and create a sense of
actually obviously sense of nature
without it being nature in this library
at UC Berkeley we're also very very
interested in the light and how it
influences and gives a sense of relief
to the interior space libraries are
essentially big boxes and so this is a
big box cracked open with light and the
stairs in the cascading under the light
which we did it folk art our way by
which we assure that people want to walk
essentially sua space rather than using
an automated method just an interior
near Lincoln Center which was a publicly
owned publicly a public privately owned
public space I'm sorry that's merely a
vestibule of Lincoln Center has become a
kind of a 24-7 destination it's
literally open 365 days a year from the
in the morning till ten at night and
then this church in Washington DC which
is really a kind of interior space we're
working within the shell of a developer
building
and the developer bought the church's
site and put them a building and then
said that they would build them the
church so it's to our context working
one making the whole building and then
we are really only shaping the interior
space for this church but it's an
interesting challenge because the
outside of the building is extremely
cold and this does connect to the
outside through windows that are filter
the light from the street to the
interior space so you're aware of it but
your shelter well the Barnes Foundation
with this courtyard and once again it's
bringing light down to a lower level so
this is really the basement but it
doesn't feel like the basement because
the light comes and penetrates all week
and not only bring the light down there
but you formulate activities are on this
light well and you step in to the small
garden so it's not just the location for
the bathroom which it is we're an
auditorium like this which it is but you
step out of the auditorium or the
library or a small cafe and even the
shop and you can see connected to nature
okay so we're going to go now and
relatively quickly because we have about
a little over half an hour show you five
projects where we feel like we're
addressing all of these issues and just
to sort of remind you it's about the
presence of the land the presence of the
human or the hand presence of material
specificity to place and focus on the
interior and that's something that
everybody in architecture learns and
thinks about it's not special to us but
these are things that sort of
continually inform the work that we do
and really based on the sort of beliefs
inform the choices that we make ready
hit it baby okay so this is a project at
Bennington College Bennington's an
unusual school
bennington vermont and we were asked to
do a center which would draw people
together so they could think about large
and important issues the center was to
have six rooms and be largely seminar
spaces few people come but some people
come to stay in bennington in the town
which is five miles away or so but very
few people stay on campus was to draw
interesting and powerful calm
conversations to the campus and what you
see is we had a choice of placing it
anywhere and what we did is we place the
building in this campus behind a
wonderful building but which was
actually there loading dock they're dead
did Jesus dead okay done okay we can
move on we placed it by their loading
dock and then we used as a way by which
we could help to clean a farm on that is
a feature of the campus so this really
indicates that the shaping of the land
and in a way once again taking three
elements making one element in the three
breaking them apart and trying to make a
small sense of place or compound here
we're inverting the rules this is in
Bennington where there's snow is heavy
and in a way capturing the snow and the
rain and bring it into the interior
courtyards so these are inverted rules
so the three buildings the long bar is
actually a place where people can stay
so it's a series of rooms that you can
spend the night in when you're at this
building it's called the Center for the
Advancement of public action we thought
it would be interested interiors we
wanted students to walk right through
that building without going into it
necessarily we also wanted to make sure
that every room was unique and every
night so that each time you would like
to go back to another room in the large
square building you can see has a
seminar room where people get together
they'll be able to sit at the
rectangular table and then a sort of
little mini interview n situation so
people can observe
also participate and then the small
building is a building that has no
particular clear program although it's
used as a seminar space but it's also a
kind of open space where students can
make determine your own activity so as
if we pulled that small space from the
center of the bigger building and stuck
it on the land bennington is a place
where there's a great deal of marble
once was an incredibly the largest
marble producing location in the world
but marble fell out of popularity
because granite is more durable and when
they were able to cut the granite with
the diamond saw a lot of them all marble
quarries fell into complete sort of well
they went to Italy yeah so and that's
where they produced the saws and other
produced in China so this is a marvel
wasteland just north of Bennington and
we had the idea of reusing this wasted
marble so some of these blocks are 100
years old 150 years old and we like very
much this pathway in front of this
Congregational Church because it was
just whatever blocks of marble they had
so we went to the desert of marble
graveyard and chose these blocks on
realizing that there is going to be a
lack of consistency and actually a lack
of consistency in terms of materialism
is something that we're very very
interested in you can see here that the
contractor because it was a very simple
building laid out the marble on the
floor of a warehouse and that allowed us
to then look at the marble and determine
if there are some areas that were too
dark or too light and rearranged them
what we did very little of that we've
driven the contractor crazy but well it
also enabled them to do is to dry the
marble and then set up a system for
putting the marble up in the building so
it went up rather well and the building
in the wintertime across from the pond
the building's tops or dead level the
buildings sit on slightly different
topography as you can see the idea of
solidity is very very important to us
the bowlers you see actually came from
the site so we just allow them to
protrude we looking out to the pond that
center space takes the snow and the rain
and drops it in the winter if it's
really cold and it's known as it did
last year they can turn on heating it
then takes that water cleans the water
neither we uses or sends it into the
pond so this is that courtyard which is
all edge glass so you're there you're in
a quite silent place and this is a space
around the courtyard originally we
thought we would make the glass clear
and then we realized you would always
feel inside a fishbowl and by making it
a CH then you have a sense of privacy
and containment and it also is a better
light reflector when you edge the glass
that sort of conference room with it
with the current tables here we used a
fabric that was designed in the 50s and
it's a kind of fractured letters you're
going to slowly okay so one of these
seminars it's a slightly dish space
where you can look out actually to the
wall of the residential building we also
sometimes use very big blocks because
you could see the action of the Warriors
on the blocks and it was very beautiful
so they're like picture stones and then
this is a space that students use 2474
their own seminars it's really a
student-run space both seminars the
residential block where we're in a way
bringing the snow and the rain into it
that obviously spills a little bit over
the pavement there where we brought wood
outside under shelter and then go into
each individual room where we used every
room head
hand glazed how I know we did a little
crazy with our interiors here and every
room a unique view and certain details
like a little sunken place to read next
to your bed so you're down lower and
feel like you're not powering over the
bed we used even some pink pink oh and
it's an amazing that's a special I love
that very tall pink and then this is
that small space the kind of
unprogrammed space there's actually only
natural light here yeah and in a very
little bit of floor warming so it can
rain inside the space and the roof opens
by manual manually and we chose to
change the color so that it would be a
kind of Yves Klein blue and they use it
actually for seminar spaces for crow
events in this case pants the next two
simple buildings at Haverford we've done
two dormitories before the one at
Princeton UVA this one was you can see
the red marks or the part of the land
that we worked on its hebbar for it is
at arboretum outside of and a college a
small college outside of Philadelphia
the our breathing is important that is a
Quaker school is important so you see
these two bars and then you see the odd
shape in the middle and the odd shape in
the middle is actually dirt and the dirt
is much part of the architecture is the
tube our buildings so we were given a
program that said we'll make three-story
buildings three and a half storey
buildings double loaded corridors
singles doubles in quads and if we look
at this we can see that the area of that
of each floor that number was 10,500 the
same area here is what we chose to do
with 507 feet permit rather than 700 and
then a common space that is larger than
the common space that they had proposed
we did that by essentially making a mutt
of fatter shorter building and that gave
us more common space and that enabled us
to make a higher-quality building what
we did then was to remove an elevator in
to fire stairs and then use the slope of
the land and stack two very dumb
buildings exactly on top of one another
concrete block buildings precast plank
buildings and then use the land to
connect the building so the buildings
here are using the slope of the land is
green or yellow things inside our
material that cannot be that can be used
inside a body of the earth but can't as
Phil and support they can't really
support a building so repack to the
material below the parking lot right so
the existing parking lot once we found
there's all this crap down below we
piled the crap together and then put
dirt on top of it but what tops saying
about the two separate buildings is that
essentially from one building from the
top floor to the bottom floor there are
no interior stairs so they actually are
separate so when you want to go out to
see a friend who lives down below you go
out across a bridge and then downstairs
outside our thesis to the students was
that the land is your is your common
space and the students then accepted
darkness this is a master plan where we
might do some more buildings but we've
just done the two buildings today there
well there there are three years old
they're extremely simple this is the
steps that go to the berm the land
slopes 120 down and 12
so that everything is successful and
they're made of this rather wonderful
German Dutch Danish brick and using wood
windows we were able to get higher
quality work and more space for the
students by using the land well I think
I also sometimes simplifying the form we
can spend more money on material that
we're making the form from so this
concrete retaining walls and slope grass
slopes once again one here on the top
have little stairs into the land and
then this is the residual space the
yellows the residual or common space and
here we've used oak doors and oak floors
and then we've created a wall covering
here of felt it's a synthetic fellow
three years later after these being used
it's it's in perfect shape today so
we're using Heath tile as a lower lower
level protection on the walls and then
this is a synthetic acrylic film that is
industrially made but we made the
patterns at the ends of the halls our
little places to sit every student
wanted a single room that made it
expensive but we were able to do it for
the budget so we have these nice little
kitchens the courtyard a little living
room area even the bathrooms are
individual bathrooms small Reading area
that looks out into the woods well every
stall is its own no it was a little
horrifying because you know the sort of
coed dorms where you're actually in a
stall next to somebody and so it was
very so we did make actual small rooms
that you can go into so here you have
some sense of privacy this is the study
area and then here looking into the
bedrooms the furniture is very simple
but we we designed it and proportioned
it so that within such a small room you
can get actually quite a few
permutations so the bed is a lot is that
the the room is wide enough so that you
can put the bed down at the far end on
one side of the other could even stack
you know that if you wish and the
bathrooms we wanted to even detail well
then the senator courtyard is a kind of
light unifier next project is in Hong
Kong and this this also is once again
taking a program in using the land to
make the buildings to give presents to
the buildings so the site is set far
back from the water's edge but it used
to be much closer but of course there's
been a lot of landfill in Hong Kong so
the land has been extending out but it's
in a very busy site in central you can
see the Hong Kong Shanghai Bank fair but
it had been uh it had belonged to the
the army and was really an abandoned set
of barracks from the British so the
earliest buildings were from 1848 the
latest ones from the 30s this is the
slope of the of the site the British had
created a platform there for the making
and cabling of munitions down to their
boats and so this is a restoration we
actually made one this is a competition
model
where we made really one building and a
series of connections between restored
buildings so that's the concept yellow
is our work red is the work we restore
it and we also chose to restore the
landscapes though they're there there's
a c-shaped red building didn't have to
be kept we kept it the other three
buildings were kept and then the
landscapes were kept and restored well
the landscapes are really important
because their military landscapes so
they're berms that were constructed with
stone walls around them and filled with
dirt because the buildings on either
side of them carried black powder so
what they wanted to do was if one
building exploded they wanted to make
sure that it didn't catch the other
building on fire and explode it so
they're almost there certainly as much
presence on the on the site as the
building's themselves I should also say
that conceptually this is a kind of
chinese garden horizontal garden in a
vertical City we did cut through one
berm you can see at the bottom in order
to make it easier to pass along to the
last building which was a theater so all
of the mechanical is buried the
buildings that are seen from above
there's all everything on the as seen
from the air is should be beautiful so
it's a it's you know in many ways how
can you make a horizontal building
that's more vertical building that's
more powerful than another vertical
building so we decided that it's better
to make a horizontal building in a
vertical plans gate because once again
it's both connected but it sets itself
apart so this is looking at the c-shaped
building and our new building yeah the
GG building which is there was one that
you saw in the previous images that's
restorative we then created this
retaining wall on a building behind it
Bonnie entry was there it actually came
up through the GG building that's the
restored building obviously done a
little bit of
largely restored it then to the left and
separated by only eight or so feet is
the new building you arrived undercover
so very hot sometimes a very hot and
money soon kind of landscape so cars can
only go this far you'd get out and walk
past that wall which is a kind of green
picture stone and enter into a garden so
you pass around that wall and suddenly
all of the sounds of the city disappear
we use a roof table of water to drop
water down to amplify the sound of water
that's rushing beneath us where we're
standing so so there's two levels
there's this level which is a lower
bridge and then there's the upper level
you send the stairs and you get to the
upper level that's what you saw from the
aerial image that table of water and
that's the upper Bridge so there are two
ways of walking across a kind of cut
through the land it's called a nulla and
in Hong Kong when it rains the water
rushes down through from the mountains
through the Noah so we're really uniting
two sections of the site this this plane
up here is dead level with the existing
British plane was created and the
incline walk blow comes up and tracks
the upper one so one shades the other
and actually is a way by which we bring
utilities to the upper site you can see
in that crude drawing of a structure
which tried to sit as little on the land
as possible we're looking back to the
new building a single new building with
the cafe serves and the roof now we're
on the we're the same plane as we were
on but we're that's great the upper site
so this canopy is what we did that
canopy captures water stainless steel
pipes then we saves the water that gives
you shelter the tracks were tracks that
were there to carry the munitions out to
cable it down to the to the ship the
buildings are restored a landscape is
restored this was a munitions building
and the walls were granted 8 feet thick
so in fact we only needed to put the air
conditioning below and we needed no
actual barrier to the outside because
the installation was so great this is
the firm that we cut through and you can
see that the overhead covering also kind
of winds a path and then the final
building which is been turned into a
theater looking back on the roof toward
the mountains peak etc and looking back
to the city so a lot of our work today
is in a way dealing with existing
conditions and then the next one is
certainly another place where we're
dealing with an existing condition at
the same time we're building a new a new
building so these are there's this one
and one more project two more projects
so this is a project in Mumbai and the
person who commissioned just actually
went to architecture school at Cornell
his name is Ratan Tata and he said that
he was interested in our work because
was another mistake right Bob yeah
perhaps even worse than Princeton he was
interested in our work because we
respected nature and there are many
banyan trees in the campus because we're
interested in material culture and
because we're interested in craft not
having our own signature but rather
trying to blog or connect so this was
the site actually just after the large
there was a large storage building that
was removed at primary accuracy and
industrial buildings that were removed
so we attempted to restore the existing
buildings working with our Indian
architect and then add buildings but
keep as many of the trees as possible so
early sketches not the very earliest
sketch
but a sketch it began to be the final
scheme where we were having the
building's dodge the trees to wherever
it was possible and essentially it's a
technology campus so people are writing
software but these fingers then finger
out into the land and then there's a
kind of main building which is the the
longer building that's running from top
to bottom which is sort of
administration our idea was to try to
not fully develop the land and brought
Tata agreed with that instead of putting
5,000 people there we put 2,500 people
there and we made sure the buildings
will be lower than the canopy of the
trees were no higher than those so this
is the overall plan it's complex the art
area and red has been completed the area
and yellow is under construction in the
area and purple will start pretty soon
that it's been 12 years so things happen
at their own at their own speed in India
and we better move along okay now I am
hugging okay so this is the building
from google map this is the main entry
and one of the big banyan trees and here
we use china tile which is a traditional
indian method of making roofs to clad
both the underside in the top of the
canopy in all of the roofs so you're
always under if you need to be under
shade and away from the Sun and the
monsoon we did a pretty good job here we
edit made the rules completely of a
membrane and then have added their
traditional roofing which is China tile
on top of that brick better construction
it's very beautiful because it's a
really village-based craft so they will
grow and it's really a woman base craft
so that the women will come they all our
friends a tile around themselves and
then they look and they tile in between
so if you look at the roof after they're
done you can sort of see the outline of
where each person was sitting because
you see the circle that they
here we made a idea of a structure that
is a jolly that would carry us on an
upper level from one building to the
other and we used stone panels that
there are only two and a half inches
thick to separate you from the beam
which you see that it's a railing and
then a second panel so it's a China tell
bridge that gives you shelter from the
Sun but you can also see this landscape
form so in many ways you take the things
that you find in other places and so the
berms were so powerful in in Hong Kong
and so that we're sort of thinking about
how to control the land in a very
architectural going up to shandur ago
you look at the work of next-gen and see
how incredibly he's felt the fit those
those walls into the land so these are
the the Jolly screens that that one
walks by they give you shelter from the
life but allow you to look out breezes
come through through the floors and out
through the stone grills so you can see
how the in the section how the land
rises up in the building stay flat and
so by the far end of the building
they're actually set quite down below
the level of the grade we wanted to make
sure they had plenty of light but never
use shades so all of the windows are
deep set in and shaded from the Sun here
they've just this was last spring when
they just finished planting the berms
and although we don't have photographs
after the monsoon this is completely
verdant though so these are ways by
which we looked and made sure that
people could look out to the landscape
but did not need shades and and with a
very very few exceptions that work so
all of the circulation and social spaces
are outdoors under cover and all fire
stairs are stairs that you use on a
daily basis we reuse the wood from
godowns or warehouses to the teak very
irregular peak to credit create warm
spaces this is a walkway leading to one
of the workstations so this is really
where people recreates now
hang out but they do do work and their
workstations here each of the pods is 50
person pod that can be broken down and
these are have very very large sheets of
glass but the Sun never enters they look
out to the tunnels of light that are
produced in the fountains so the
courtyards that they look at you are
actually roofed with these very big
oculi that bring light down and then
there are these very large funds that's
fantastic is that this actually even in
the hottest times is always cool breezes
are always filtered through here we
worked with a collective of women taking
standard ecat patterns and making them
much larger and then use those as wall
hangings to bring color and once again
the China tiles coming inside on that
form this is a little ridiculous we
suggested the this campus they needed a
swimming pool so they made a swimming
pool this is a concrete proof to make
sure it's not so hot there and you look
out to the landscape shielded Sheila but
any rate this is a wonderful place to be
i would say that the employees are
extremely happy with a variety of
different things that enable them to be
there you know essentially 24-7
obviously that's a Microsoft idea sort
of makes your life at Bloomberg idea
make sure life is so sweet and do want
to go home or maybe it's Yale and this
is the final project we're showing
tonight it's a skating center that's in
brooklyn in Prospect Park it's
interesting look at Central Park and
then prospect park at the same scale
prospects bark park is smaller it was
the second ten years after Central Park
and it's always considered the sort of
step child but
Vox thought it was equally good and they
had three things that they particularly
liked a much larger artificial lake a
much longer meta a mile and a quarter in
a much deeper woods our project is there
and this was an area in this image of
their plans this is an area was a kind
of recreational area they called it
music grove and a carriage turn about at
a place to skate on the artificial lake
back in the late 1800s thundering the
moat Robert Moses years the carriage
turn around became a huge parking lot
and then music Island was filled in and
outdoor skating rink west point on that
a very inefficient rink and let's go
back Billy just to show that will be
done with this quickly so music Island
is the little island it never really
worked musicians were supposed to go out
there by boat play two people waiting in
the concert grove that's why Moses
probably put the pool there the the rink
there but it was a very inefficient rink
our assignment at first was to make an
indoor rink and we thought it would be
better not to do that because they're so
incredibly expensive and they're so
large so what we did is proposed one
cover drink in one freeform rink and
they'd be connected and that the
landscape in a way that they sit exactly
in the location of the parking lot and
meanwhile the concert music Alan would
be restored so this is an image of it
last winter the roof of the canopy
there's a continuous green roof and the
planting is just coming in so this is
both a hockey rink regulation hockey
rink and free skating connected by
little channel and then in the
summertime it becomes roller skating
and a big water play area and one of the
nice things was this kind of was
considered not one of the sort of lesser
loved areas of brooklyn and of the park
and so the park was really wanting to
invest a lot of money into it in order
to make it part of the more loved areas
of the park and particularly because at
least up until recently and still
recently is an area that serves a less
wealthy so this is the restored water's
edge and we really had nothing to do
with this we work with the landscape
architect with the christian zimmerman
and then our canopy that covers the
Boston Garden size a skating rink it
just just now because it's getting cold
enough as they put ice back on it the
shape shields it from rain and from from
snow for the most part and they're all
sound light fixtures these are trees
that were planted by Olmstead inbox 150
years ago and the building is in fact an
intrusion in the park but it also helps
to frame the landscape and it's a pretty
quiet intrusion this is one of the more
noisy images we wanted to use New York
schist but we had to go to Canada to
find inexpensive stone that was the
curbing stone that was chopped for the
blocks because in fact all of the parks
are made of rather crude stone and so we
just once again deforming the land to
make sure that both surfaces are we both
add some and subtract some so we walk on
top of the buildings without noticing it
so the buildings are buried and they're
retained by these big curbing walls and
this is the primary entrance when you
come and enter the park so it doesn't
really announce itself so much as a
building as a series of walls and
lansky you rent your skates there were
the person only thing you pay for is
renting the ice skates and being on the
ice itself otherwise it's open to
everyone at all times their classrooms
they're more public bathrooms here that
have been added for the entire park the
park add and then the canopy is just a
series of normal lights as mechanical we
always want to make sure that every part
of the building as good as every other
part so well not not you and me but let
me tell you Andy I'm not hiding yeah and
then we made marks in the ceiling which
is just an eephus apathetic 'if of
ceiling but we carved it and then we use
the light on the ice to reflect to these
silver marks that suggest perhaps
skaters so these are summertime and the
ice on the outside becomes a water plant
summer it's really great to see this
used from the upper level so parents and
friends and just onlookers can watch the
crazy sort of choreography of little
kids either on ice skates and roller
skates which is pretty amazing they can
fall down and get up so many times
summer
a winter view from the upper level and I
think you know we're ending with this
coach is that we see architectures and
act of profound optimism the foundation
lies in believing that is possible to
make places on the earth that can give a
sense of grace to life and believing
that that matters it is what we have to
give and it is what we leave behind we
measure the value of our work by the
quiet pleasure of the lives lived in our
buildings this work is made by two hands
but it's also made by many heads thank
so we thank you for a beautiful talk and
beautiful work and beautiful timing
everything perfect and just the right
amount of bickering yeah it was perfect
it was perfect I I don't know if there
are questions but if there are and those
of you who are visitors we do try to
follow our lectures with Q&A period so
please feel free to ask a question if
you have one sometimes I call on the
faculty Oh admit so here's a question I
am two questions one is a question about
the relationship of your architecture to
the city as opposed to nature because
you are New York architects and they've
had some experiences there that we all
know about and it seems almost every
project turns inward and doesn't make a
face or a relationship directly to say a
city street or something like that the
second is another thing that I hadn't
really noticed before the work is the
this in in spite of all the interest in
the hand in the individual that the
buildings have a level of monumentality
and they achieve and I wonder if you
have a comment about that or is that
something recognizing your own work or
something you actually shoot for in the
design yeah so the first question is
about relationship to a city and you
know I think of one house that we did in
New York City actually
haven't done that much in New York City
and but it does I it's true that I think
our buildings turn inward and don't open
out to the city and I think probably
that's partly coming from a desire to
make to make the interior important so
that you need to go through that wall
and then see the interior that the
interior is not something that's there
for all to see so we think it's a
special and important experience and we
think grant glass for example is
promiscuous means almost nothing but it
is a solid solid barrier and so I don't
I'm not a believer in that my parents my
parents transparency and monumentality
you're right i think that because we are
so interested in the intimate experience
we are also concerned with gathering the
energy we have in creating something
that feels powerful and other and i
would say that i would like somehow a
sense of monumentality or a sense of a
larger idea to be present both inside
and also outside but it's always in
balance I think also it has to do with
this desire to make eggs last make
buildings
like this building feels like it's here
it's really yeah but I mean there are
lots of ways that we can't that the
rendering of a canopy is a painting I'm
sorry is it an act of some arrogance
some money infidelity a sense of making
a sense of power out of that ceiling
flame so and I think that has very
little to last except maybe for memories
yeah but I think that the idea of the
sense of monumentality comes from the
solidity which is something that also
goes back to this idea what face you're
giving to a city and I think that we
because we want the build we want things
to feel heavy on the ground even small
things to feel heavy on the ground so
Bennington is pretty small that feels
pretty heavy on the ground and I think
that leads to that sense of
monumentality so solidity and material
it's like there I always show these
students the images of this early joel
shapiro sculptures and their tiny little
houses and you walk into a gallery
they're just sitting on the floor
they're about this big and but you feel
like they weigh like you would never be
so i think that's a kind of well also
think it's largely missing today and
work this done so we are also trying to
stand apart what that was the zinger
this is Inga now he's okay
just got a third of our faculty that's
all right are there any other questions
I'm sure the Peggy demon has a question
we need to get a mic to you Peggy boo
remember there are people in other rooms
that need to hear your question
to figure out what is provia with not
just the materials with the flavors in
they're also comes with expense I guess
we're talking about that about the hand
and
and I'm curious to know how you position
yourself around the maintenance of
crafts my views appearing at the same
time that it comes with well i think
that the craft of making a large plant
as we just saw a few slides ago is craft
I'm sorry that's the the chilling plant
for the goddamn ring that to me is equal
craft and that takes a huge amount of
personal commitment in the organization
of the pipes and I'm sorry the placing
of concrete is cracked it means that
every person whose value that every
moment in our lives should be valued and
yes does it cost more I think it values
the person to care about that person
giving their craft to the work that it
certainly comes with expense and we
better build that into the budgets and
we don't we don't make arbitrary budgets
the budgets are made a perfect example
being hammer for the budget was made and
we had to live with the budget so we
found a way by which we could deliver
the craft for the money I think that's
responsible it would rather have done
enough crappy things in my life that
don't last and don't least feel proud to
know that they don't honor the person or
they honor the building that they do
cost less and first costs so i'm i'm
sorry i'm a believer and emptying that
wallets of the people that that paid to
have the building's made and i believe
that that's just the correct use of the
their their their gift of the of the
commission I guess part of the question
to maybe your answer this you know when
you're making the analogy with the
mechanical system at the prospect ice
rink but the idea that craft doesn't
just reside with with the hand but that
there's a craft with high technology too
and that the systems that you use and
themselves how you deploy them and how
you procure them are their own craft as
I'm there's a way that the craft
can also enter into the non hand the non
extensive way night which I which I
think you care about but i'm just i'm
curious I guess the question was really
about whether you feel that there is a
dedication to crafts that might
disappear and hence there's a agenda
there or not that's not necessarily how
your I just think the crafts exist
everywhere I think might exist I see it
everywhere throughout America or India
they exist everywhere these people are
there and you know i'd rather make a
fire stare like this fire stare be one
that i want to be an in-home that I
don't want to be up and that should be
crafted so I would put those tiles there
to enhance that experience that one
usually kicks into the corner so I it's
not really about it's not about honoring
craft or trying to keep crafts live I
mean that's why we use the walk-off mats
in the east asian library it doesn't
bother of course i'd like to use
handmade work when i can
I think the issue is to make a space
where you recognize that you care and a
person that comes there recognizes they
do have terrible so it's just don't
think about that Peggy we have to be
responsible the budget but I think what
you're doing is you're enlarging the
idea of what is craft yeah because one
can make things in the best sense of
like way trust Trust trust me and you do
get obsessive and go a little too far in
certain places unnecessarily so I'm well
aware that going too far with that
obsession or interested crowd making it
apparently there's a question quite far
back a lady Europe we need to give her
the mic know for the back ways to your
put your if you want to ask the question
you got to put your hand up it's not a
halfway thing here you have to speak
into the mic there are like five rooms
of people who need to hear what you're
saying okay I was wondering when you
think about monumentality and
timelessness do you ever sketch or
imagine what the building like the
skating rink will look like when it's
maybe void of its original function yeah
because it will last a while I mean
right Dan it's hard to imagine the
future that's all I would say I try to
really think about the present now and
do it as well as we can and yeah that's
thing is I I like it when buildings are
used and
when the landscape grows in and then
engulfs the buildings but I it's hard to
imagine that except to say you know let
the building and be engulfed by the land
and what the use is I mean the
technology campus i'm hoping will be
actually a college campus one day that
would be an appropriate use for that i
think i've thought about that but I they
don't give a damn what I think about
happy no they want the technology campus
to keep on going so just I was telling
them that doesn't mean too much we have
time for maybe one more ? gage we're
just going to follow up with the
statement that it's hard to imagine the
future you get one could also say that
the future won't come unless we imagine
it and I wonder if you know the i'm sure
that at least all the faculty or you
know dying to know more but the folk art
museum but the question of that is maybe
you know didn't was the future of that
building not perhaps not anticipated
enough was it too precious for its
specific use and it was so fantastic for
its original use but can you comment on
that well I I mean I look back I mean
this is a parent who's lost a child
let's say it's not I'm sorry I'm so it's
not a child but is you go think of the
drift you know and you cannot help when
that happens to wonder how you
contributed to that and we did done so
would you different I could list about
five or six things I wouldn't the first
thing is well you don't need to know
that I would shoot later five or six
things that would still not make the
building different it would go anyway
because moment didn't want it there I we
thought we were making connect
we actually sent our drawings to
taniguchi and he actually lined up a
floor just with ours quietly without
telling moment we thought maybe we're
anticipating the future there but we did
a bunch of other things that didn't
anticipate the future and we didn't
really me actually thought it could last
and that probably was silly but but what
we did and contributed to a very simply
I believe that you could put an air
barrier so you wouldn't have a vestibule
in the building I mean to what extent
did running an air barrier over a single
set of doors which I thought would bring
us closer to the street and I'm sorry I
wanted to bring people to the street
without a master bill that would help
and I realized it didn't do a good
enough job perfect example but there one
after another but i don't think that
brought the building down the building
is gone and we're responsible someone
else is too okay all right is there
anyone who has an irresistible last
question all right there's there an
irresistible last question it better be
good well we'll see i see a sense of
play in your work and somehow that seems
to come through through the roofs and
also in the roof of the ice skating rink
and i wondered if maybe you could speak
about play in your work
it's funny I think that this sort of
when you say play I don't think we're
exactly a playful office but I think in
our studio there's a sense of both
commitment and relaxation and so I think
in that we are balanced sometimes ideas
come floating in that are not within a
sort of tight stricture of the sort of
beliefs like monumentality or lasting
are being heavy and we think of moments
of beauty we think of architectural
promenade we think of moments of
surprise we think it's harder to control
this surface which has you know several
hundred people on it than that surface
which is a little easier control more
playing but this space so we do what we
can to give joy to our buildings and
sometimes it's playful one thing I would
say to all people who are considering
coming to this school if I were going to
go to our protector school now I would
come here
you